member states today agreed to improve
European criminal records information
system with the information about the
first contra nationals and stateless
persons actually for five years actress
has not only covered two information
about EU nationals can fight against
cross-border crime and also in fight
against terror this is a very important
step further second file where the
council reached a general approach today
is a regulation on mutual recognition of
freezing and confiscation orders for the
study of Europe poll actually we're able
to get only 1% of
criminal profit and this is surely not
the level which a it's okay the crime
shouldn't pay and we need more
instruments why we are doing that
because for too long criminals in Europe
could escape justice because the EU
authorities could not exchange the
information fast enough and also for too
long criminals in Europe enjoy quasi
impunity because the law enforcement
cannot cost confiscate their assets we
are arming ourselves to disrupt and cut
off criminals and terrorists financial
means we also
spoke about solutions for
providing safety
and legal clarity in issues which
concern cross-border family matters and
we must keep in mind that the special in
children related cases the time is a
crucial factor
decisions in cross-border cases should
be enforceable as swiftly as possible